we've been telling you about the
flooding in various areas yesterday into
today there was also flooding at zion
national park it washed out a road
that goes right through the park
washington county officials and zion
national park rangers cleaning mud from
the entrance
park officials want visitors to know
that traffic will be hectic
for the next day or two
tuesday was an unnerving day for the
griffin family visiting zion national
park from california
we decided to hike up the emerald pool
so we did that for a little bit and we
heard the thunder so
decided out of safety to come back down
we headed to the lodge to pick up the
shuttle and
a sudden downpour
then came the hail alexa griffin says
that's when she and her family saw mud
sliding down
and water flowing through we sat there
and for about two hours kind of just
waiting out to really know what happened
we saw
tractors and everything coming down to
get the rocks out the aftermath flooding
all over the park
debris and rock piles and trapped cars
we don't really get this
i don't remember in california
especially in the bay area
while flash floods remain possible
wednesday visitors say they're just
happy they got out safe
new trails in the park are closed as
well as the oversized vehicle lot which
you saw there park rangers say make sure
to plan ahead check the website of
course for more information